hi I'm Carl Zimmer a columnist for The
New York Times and I'm in conversation
with Heather Berlin a neuroscientist at
the Icahn School of Medicine at Mount
Sinai
so Heather Ivy genius is this word that
we all use but I am really curious what
people like you think about the word
yeah I guess well I mean I can describe
it looking through it my lens as a
neuroscientist I mean I think just the
word genius is a really all-encompassing
term and what we try to do is kind of
break it down into the constituent parts
and try to understand the neural
mechanisms that drive those things so
for example I think a really big part of
what it means to be a genius is to have
a great deal of creative or like novel
thinking making these novel associations
between ideas having a lot of pattern
detection so it's not just about
collecting a bunch of data and knowing a
lot of facts but it's making these novel
connections between ideas and I think
what we want to look at is for example
what is the neural correlate of
something like divergent thinking or
thinking outside the box having having
novel associations between ideas and
that's the kind of thing that we can
begin to measure so how can you measure
something like that so it's been
actually quite a problem how to quantify
this not just genius but let's say
creativity and we're breaking it down
particularly what I'm interested in is
is improvisation so when people are
being spontaneously creative and what
was that important to you what does that
get it so I think that a lot of what's
happening in the brain is happening
outside of awareness and we when we're
when we have our sort of conscious brain
highly active it's it's kind of
suppressing a lot of what's going on
outside of wines and sometimes when
people are being creative they say it
almost feels like things are coming from
outside of them when they're in this
sort of flow state and we're starting to
understand a little bit more about that
state and it seems to be that when
people are being creative in the moment
that the part of their brain that has to
do with their sense of self always self
awareness self consciousness is turned
down it's called the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex where is it it's sort
of like right here it's part of the
prefrontal cortex on the
dorsal on the lateral sides so you can
actually see that change like the
activity in there is changing and these
kinds of situations yeah so for example
there's been a few studies and we're
doing a new one now but in in the
studies all seem to show that for
example when a jazz musician is
improvising compared to when he doesn't
memorize piece or even a rapper when
he's doing a freestyle rap compared to
doing a memorized rap there's a similar
pattern of activation across the
improvising rappers and the improvising
jazz musicians and they have a decreased
activation in that dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex which has to do with
self-awareness monitoring your ongoing
behavior making sure it conforms with
social norms but they have also
increased activation in a part of the
brain called the medial prefrontal
cortex which is sort of like right here
a little if you go straight back a
little bit and that is turned up and
that has to do with the internal
generation of ideas it's coming from
within its stimulus independent so if
you think of this state you're having
this sort of free flow of unfiltered
information coming from within that's
not being inhibited by that dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex you don't have
to worry about how do people think about
me and that free flow of information
allows for the novel associations to be
made if you think about a similar
pattern of brain activation happens
during dreams or during daydreaming or
metis some types of meditation or
hypnosis where you lose your sense of
self and time and place and it allows
the filter to come off so that novel
associations are okay you know dreams
don't all make sense that's where the
creativity comes in so that's why I'm
interested in that state to see what
happens in people when they're in that
state because I think that's a big part
of what is involved with genius so I'm
picturing like someone in a scanner
wrapping and it's hard to picture so I
mean what how did what does it look like
I mean how do you I mean experiments are
so difficult to set up you've figured
something out so how does it work yeah
so what we're doing is and again it's
hard to make something ecologically
valid or sort of simulate what it's like
in the real world when you're laying in
this you know tube and there's this big
clicking sound so what it is is so
there's a loud clicking noise in the
scanner and we
picked a beat that matches the clicking
beat in the scanner you know so that
it's not distracting and what we do is
in one condition we have them do a
memorized rap and there was a similar
study that was done by another group in
a small group of rappers but we've kind
of elaborated on that and we know in the
improvised state we have we show them
random images and they have to improvise
and incorporate those images into their
rap in real time and we're giving them
real-time audience feedback so we're
having other professional rappers with
the dial going up or down because that's
part of the real world situation when
you're improvising it's about audience
feedback whether it's comedy improv
theater improv and we want to see how
that feedback affects their their sort
of creativity but how does that feedback
and other people being aware of other
people listening to you how's that
connect with your ideas about how these
circuits are involved with the self are
coming down when you're being creative I
mean I would think like you know if
you're in that flow state you could be
performing in front of an empty room
because you're just all it's all about
what's coming from within yeah so what
we think is there there so there's
something called the default mode
Network and that seems to be sort of
active it's sort of a neuro circuit of
the brain that's active when you're your
focus of attention is internal so when
they're kind of flow state we see
activation of the default mode Network
but what we think is that there's
occasionally this they have to monitor
the environment seeing you know how am i
doing what is it so then they'll switch
into what's called the executive network
which is looking externally instead of
joining different knit circuit of
neurons we're talking about
yeah I'm sure flipping back and forth
yeah between these two sort of
internally focused and generating new
ideas and externally focused kind of to
monitor your situation because if you
think about it when if you just are
having a random flow it's not like a
jazz musician is just playing random
notes or rappers just saying random
words it has to make sense you know it
has to be kind of have a certain appeal
and so you do have to monitor at some
level if it's just like a dream state
although it's getting at that novel
thinking it's not necessarily being
creative because
just random thoughts with making no
sense isn't isn't really what we're
looking for either so there's that
switching back and forth between the two
networks
you